man upgrades first ever voice controlled
[__] machine activated by the words
finish me
stick around
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population U
population cross David Cross welcome
is it just me or is it uh am I the mayor
and yes
who are the Comptroller okay interim the
alderman well this is a return for you
to the tax you have been here
I do like that the Bursar
um no you did this uh during the
pandemic you were in your audience
resumed it so much more fun to be home
okay so my question miles away my
question to you is do you believe that
even in the time from when you did it in
your comfortable confines of your home
to hear that the world has gotten Dumber
in that small of a period of time have
we accelerated how dumb it's become yeah
I don't think it's exponentially Dumber
I think it's uh increasingly Dumber I
don't think it's uh smarter more no
we're on a rickety ramp dump yeah yeah
we're like the roller coasters lurching
forward we're backyard ramp it's more of
a backyard built like we built it yeah
or a Kearney and the dumb is getting
louder I feel it there is like that is
the prevailing voice I just I think it's
it's only louder because it's Dumber
meaning there's more numbers and uh yes
I mean you can hope for people dying off
I mean yeah I do we do on a daily basis
too people die yeah I just do and and
maybe stop spawning but you can hope for
um people to be Barren and you can hope
for people to die and with that let's
jump into the first book or read a book
yes I think the other two would happen
those those are like more viable yeah
yeah so shall we get into it downstairs
my friend Derek says hello oh thanks so
much our friend there our mutual friend
there we'll tell Derek I said hello back
I don't have to you just did mail it
very nice okay it was very dirty now you
have to listen now Derek you gotta
listen this you ready for this story
number one comes to us from our hometown
of St Louis Missouri St Louis Father and
Son Pokemon go team I even know that was
the thing you can be a team with I
didn't can you be sure you don't even
know what Pokemon go is explain it
Pokemon invented reality Pokemon go is
yes you you oh the initial thing where
you see you put on the or you have your
phone and then your phone and then they
pop up wherever you are that's how it
started right right and you and you flip
a little ball to catch it and you go to
certain places you know slower as though
you don't know exactly how this works
I think it's a pretty cool thing I mean
anything that gets people out and around
I'm happy for I remember I think I was
on tour when that first started getting
happening and I didn't know why people
were like giggling and there'd be like
four five six people and they'd have
their phones and then I it was happening
so frequently and then I was like what's
going on and also I kind of quickly
sussed out like oh this is a it's a game
I didn't know if it was a game but it
was something like that and then
somebody explained it and I was like
that sounds pretty cool oh it's any sort
of like role-playing game or I think
it's not just the concept of everybody
it's like a scavenger hunt right total
scavenger hunt and my son was way way
into it like super into it go to the
Santa Monica Pier all the time which I
would never go to the Santa Monica Pier
but that was a Pokemon go hot spot right
you could just be catching left and
right and I love that you could have
been a father and son team with your son
here I probably not because I'm terrible
but you were a team if that's the way
though you're identified in a newspaper
article that you are a father and son
Pokemon go team right that's the first
way of doing it you're a trainer you
have your Pokemon you train them I was a
driver now uh how and I say this I'm not
trying to be funny just complete
ignorance but how does it uh how how do
you is it a matter of like the amount of
things you catch or do they have values
or what do you have values so they're
all great questions great questions and
I would hate for you to try to be funny
on this podcast but
they are a little each one the Rarity of
the of the Pokemon they're kind of like
nfts it's basically like so if it's so I
would assume
that not everybody can see the same
otherwise you would follow other people
and just go there it is so everyone can
see the same they they all are finding
the same in each location why don't the
the game program the people program into
each location certain ones at certain
times so once the 50 get found in this
area people can still if you go to that
area you can get it you're getting it
but once you get it I think in your game
then you can't get it wouldn't there be
almost like a like a
a walk through for a game you'd play you
know on on yeah Xbox or Playstation or
something wouldn't there be like a list
you just go on the internet and go oh
there's 14 over here at the pier and you
go underneath and go that is the
hamburger and then they have gyms where
you can the ones that you've caught and
you've trained and built up to like wait
wait wait wait wait wait
yeah it's probably like modern slavery
so like the house across the street
could be designated in maps uh to be a
gym just that location yes you train
them to well once you go to the gym then
you fight the ones you've trained
against other people oh this is so far
beyond level
it's a whole world it is an entire world
that you are training cute little things
are building up like solid mass muscle
and learning Taekwondo and learning it's
like futuristic Japanese [__] fighting
you're raising a tiny little fighting to
fight in the background that was part of
it yeah that was a cute thing you did
with your kid well father and son
Pokemon go team catches assault
convictions oh my God so they got them
real fight with people over Pokemon go
we're gonna get into it sent in by
professor demerida at in C McCarthy
thank you Anna this is maybe the first
time this person hello and welcome okay
so this takes place like we said in St
Louis so we kind of know some of the
areas where it went down all right right
so I'm sorry to interrupt other people
are listening watching this this is not
just the four of us oh other people live
no not live but they will eventually no
but yeah yeah so people listen to this
through our podcast yeah sure yeah oh
yeah
just three dumb news stories that were
comedically broken down so I love how
surprised what you thought it was the
first time meaning this isn't just for
uh this isn't just for the four of us
other people are strangers people you
have been doing I love that you would if
someone
here yeah
so I promote I'm promoting my new Santa
special to three people at a time very
political door-to-door that's very guys
who would have bought it and watched it
we would have done it anyway but you
just you didn't have to come here and
we're already fans old school man I'm
doing it in person knocking doors
knocking on doors pressing the flesh so
the best part about this and we'll guess
this later is how old these people are
the father father and son I say father
and son and you get an image in your
mind
okay fine convicted Wednesday of beating
up a Pokemon competitor in a brawl that
all landed in the lake in Kirkwood Park
now we've been to Kirkwood it's a nice
part of St Louis it would have a pumpkin
patch in the around I'm saying it's uh
upper middle class folks probably I mean
it's yeah it's like a cute quaint little
area the old St Louis kind of like white
very white very white
yes I mean circle square okay St Louis
County jury found Robert matuisi and his
son Angelo metisi who we're gonna find
out how they are guilty of a felony of
third degree assault all right wait you
just told me that it there isn't a
finite Supply that if you get your thing
you've got so these guys might not know
how it works you guys explain how it
works more than a day of testimony
reveal more than a day of testimony
meanwhile someone out there who is an
enormous Pokemon go fan them having to
listen to us through the realities of it
the worst day ever losing their minds
right now Jason if you want to yeah
Randy had nothing to do with it more
than a day of testimony so whatever
happened revealed in all the testimony a
long-running virtual feud between two
teams so this is something that bubbled
over before two have gotten into it they
might fight at the gym teams and Pokemon
go players turned into a real-life
battle captured on video in June of
2018. it's now coming to light right now
at issue in the fight one Pokemon gym
you were right see does that issue
Pokemon go is an augmented reality
smartphone game that allows users to
hunt capture and do battle with virtual
Monsters by visiting real-life locations
busy places like Kirkwood Park become
coveted hot spots known as gyms that
teams can claim Dan you did a wonderful
job of explaining that one part the
matuzis were on one wait a minute back
up for a second sure yeah I'm being
serious yeah please so
so an area can be claimed which means
nobody else can claim it well the uh
programmers designate which areas it is
a gym and which is safe yes where
somebody can't fight with you
if you're in the gym somebody could
challenge you and your Pokemon to a
fight yeah the gym can be the Dunkin
Donuts that's right I got you I got you
in this case so was was the issue that
they were in the safe Zone and somebody
said we're gonna find out the issue
could have been that they're just crazy
Hot Heads who are like this is where
we're not a good game for people who
have short tempered the matusis were on
one team vying for the park while the
victim who went by the gaming name of
Sammy the bull was on another a mafia a
famous Sammy the bull gravano man right
a mafia Hitman that's how you're that's
his intimidation level that is a pretty
bold stance excuse me
the victim testified that an argument
over the right to claim the gym
escalated when the youngest I think if
you win the gym you it's your gym and
then when other people come to the gym I
see now that makes this is starting to
make more sense escalated when the
younger Tuesday started punching him
sparking a brawl that caused both of
them to fall into about how many how
fall how many feet into Walker Lake in
the park take a guess as to how far down
they fell into this why is this I'm
gonna go nine inches what do you think
10 feet what do you think like 18 feet I
think they were way down is there a
bridge I don't know they just they fell
get your answers in townies they fell uh
about five feet into the Walker the
Elder matuzzi then jumped in after his
son like you saw the video of the guy
whose puppy got eaten by an alligator or
like and he's in there fighting this is
what this guy did he saw his son go down
I mean what we wouldn't do for our kids
would get an adult man fight his son or
I'll just you've got to wait we'll get
14 and 44. 14 44. what do you think it
is I mean go with you I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go 18
and 6.
I'm gonna go 18 and 39. 1839 okay get
your answers in because the father
is 75 years old
oh my God the son Angelo is 35 years old
that's it 75 and 35. this 75 year old
man jumped in the lake after his son
first of all Kudos
[Laughter]
son help me now I'm in the double oh
we're in a rip we're in a rip it's a
lake this is a guy who waited till he
was 40 to have a child so yeah his son
is 35. yeah and so prosecutors and his
ninth
he just wanted to do something with this
child this is the one just he couldn't
bond with it that's right all the other
nine he could connect with prosecutors
Andrew Wren and Joanna Bruggeman played
jurors of video capturing the fight in
the lake showing both matuzies
reportedly repeatedly punching the
victim and holding the man down in the
water wait so they're all in the water
they're now everybody's fine oh my God
the footage was taken by a band son of
it now you gotta deal with two metoozies
but twozies does sound like a hot family
like the matuzis only shirt over his
head and started punching them and so
the man who is taking the footage
doesn't touch you in the footage just
says shouts get away from each other
right now
did that work that usually works a
younger voice can be heard saying Dad
don't get involved so sure the person
who's filming is with his son and his
son
cuts the thing off before the kid said
now's our chance to get at the gym while
these idiots are fighting let's go get
them unless they're in a Pokemon go
filming League the fathers the fight
ended when the bystander finally ran
over to the men and forced them to
separate so he had the power to do this
all along but just wanted to film it you
don't know you have the power within you
until you're right I mean maybe he this
is about the power of whatever Pokemon
a Phil Collins In the Air Tonight
remember he watched some other guy watch
some guy drown which means that he
watched him drown too he watched a guy
drowned if you watched another guy watch
a guy drive you watched a guy drop yeah
but his Focus was on the other guy yeah
this guy I'm not Kink shaming you get
off how you get off whatever Phil wants
to spank it well
another person watch someone dress fine
and you know look you do what you gotta
do the victim was left with some facial
abrasions some traumatic eye injury
broken fingertip broken fingertip that
hurts and a detached fingernail that
need to be reported in this thing that's
the thing where you're like all right
you don't you don't have to report the
Detachment that's what the complex
go why don't we just round down
wait let's just fingertip is good we
don't have to get into the you know the
book fingertips sounded so let's just
blanket It Go finger injury I didn't
know it covers everything I didn't why
do you don't have to put scratch my
tushy you don't please
it's fine it's a tiny tissue scratch
welcome to this testified in their own
defense on the trial the defense
attorney Jeffrey Raff Dave rath's
brother maybe I don't know argued that
they are not the aggressors in the melee
I didn't want to be in the water the
Father Robert matuzzi told the jury I
didn't want this kid
that's a bad don't when prosecutors
remind him that he jumped in to join his
son he replied when you're this happened
a couple years ago he's 75 now when
you're 71 and you get punched in the
head you don't know what you're doing
right right whoever is doing the exactly
who is Pokemon they make it too good you
want it you need the gym they're making
me love it too much he may not
understand that he did hold the victim's
Head Underwater so this to me is like so
I did you know I held him underwater
obviously I was trying to drown him but
he said and this was his event I just
wanted to dunk him that's what he says
yeah I just want to milk him what I
think
fun dunk we've all had fun dunks you
know when you dunk someone and you wait
for their final bubble to come up
we would have chicken fought we are
we're already a team teams are
established I love the sun Angelo
matuzzi testified that he never wanted
to fight I was just trying to put my
Pokemon in the gym he testified to a
bunch of jurors who are like we've never
you know what the [__] are you talking
about no clue what you're doing she's
trying to put them in the gym he later
reflected it was Father's Day it was
Father's Day that's what you do you
did we find out the ages of the other
people are fighting we have not yet and
I don't know but Dave you make such a
great point because I would love it if
it's like a 35 year old guy
that would really make it a much
different scenario
I'm a dunk kid needed a little dunk but
he's so right on Father's Day for the 35
year old son to make the 75 year old go
to a park while he sits on a phone and
just does this also like the other
father and son who's there's nothing
here don't don't forget it's St Louis it
is I mean there's there's almost
no nothing good about St Louis
I've been there several times there's
nothing there's our hometown over there
he left for a reason
you can't argue about the Kirkwood area
is everything I want except a reason
this is probably a great time to mention
guys that uh you'll be in St Louis I'll
be in Satan at the pageant theater at
the pageant theater I will uh part of my
worst daddy in the world tour oh nice
and by the way that is a Pokemon gym in
the back of the bar area of the pageant
is an actual Pokemon I can't wait so
I'll set it up please fights are going
official davidcross.com yes you get all
the um all the Pokemon information uh
yeah that well I'm going to attach that
now to the store now I've learned about
this so all the list of cities there
that where I'll be performing starting
on March 2nd okay in Portland uh and
I'll get all the Pokemon gym Invasion so
St Louis as a city I know we have some
St Louis fans you now have something to
prove to David Cross that's right you
show up at that pageant show and you'd
be the best damn audience you can yell
at me I don't want you to yeah no I want
I don't know to do meet and greets but I
hope the matusies show up I will be
doing a meet and greet there you go I am
a little bit Tuesdays better [__] be
there the guy pulling up in a wheelchair
how about the by Center broke up the
fight two of the victims former three
tickets for him and his son right you
get it so an emergency department doctor
and a Kirkwood police officer all
testified for the prosecution this is
clear another member of the matuzzi
family family testified for the defense
about a previous run-in between two
Pokemon go teams so this has been
they're saying it's endemic it's a
long-going thing to the game when the
answer originally at that area park so
this is when the incident originally
happened it made uh the Fresno Bee it
even made that newspaper the jury
I think Fresno is more like hey it's not
just us it's all right right hey guys I
know we're bad but guys what's going on
in Kirkwood uh I'll do it too the
matuzzi brothers and see what their
business is
m-a-t-t-e-u-z-z-i to me and I know this
sounds ridiculous but I would love it if
they sold Jacuzzis
[Laughter]
we don't know how to install these
things but we are forced by rhyming law
we don't have an option so how many days
uh was the recommended sentence that the
jury gave to Robert matuzzi how many
days in jail did they recommend for
having this fight on third degree
assault right this is a third degree
assault
I mean I don't know that stuff but I
would hope it's not more than
because I want you to run the farthest
with us the matuzzi Jacuzzis
right look at that hair on that guy
forced to be yeah you love that the who
the older guy the younger guy the older
guy the younger guy the older guy
they're both in an unreleased season of
Fargo right yeah and the guy on the left
does look like the dad does look like he
has made his hair a wig out of his own
oh the other hair that fell out yeah
he has a jacket for a place he doesn't
work at anymore
I'll tell you what uh
jacuzzi salesman not far off
by the way and you just flashed that
picture quickly I can't even tell you
who's the older one
that is what's interesting about them
that's a 75 year old man that's a guy
that that guy will sit when he gets a
few drinks in uh and just [__] about
how porn isn't the same anymore yeah for
sure you know yeah I mean I love it
there's the story words of a story why
is everyone you know why is everyone I
don't need the goddamn story too much
storage let's do my story I'm gonna tell
you this razors ruined porn
I don't need an exterior shot of a
building let's get it we don't need to
establish geography I don't even know
that they're in the art studio I don't
even need music or or the opposite no I
need to know they're in the heart Studio
why the [__] are they I've lost all
perspective I don't know who she is who
is this character now how long has this
person even been their stepdad did they
know is that a real business I need to
be born today
the man is that boy I miss the music 60
days 30 days Dan how much okay the
answer is they recommended that he be in
jail for three days either way father's
day's ruined grown man quote uh
including a man in his 70s coming to
blows over a childish game that they are
playing is ridiculous but there was
nothing funny about the injuries
sustained I love that they're like this
is before you make a joke
it's funny that these guys are so
humorous that you're all going to want
to do this but nothing's funny about
someone who could have drowned which
actually is true three days is a bit
short yeah but this is what the
prosecutor said I thank this jury for
reminding the matuzis and our community
that our parks are for play and
relaxation not violence was that their
point I don't know
we're here to make these Parks but I
think the thing just happened
spontaneously yeah there you go so
that's what it is that is Story number
one down in the books Dan I think your
second I think I am when we come back we
will tell you guys how you can get
David's new special
okay it's older I'm more concerned with
the worst daddy in the world tour yeah
all right well we'll talk about that on
the other side of the break David
crosses with us it's dumb people
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get to uh the only thing we're
going to talk about David which is his
last special
that we need to say simply just talk
about the last minute uh we will talk
about his new tour uh but speaking of
Tours we are going to be in a couple
places yes uh if this comes out I
believe if this drops before March you
guys are they're they're jumping jumping
yeah oh no we're jumping the gun yeah
and then because you're the most
important thing
no we open and then we build we always
continue to continuing to listen to the
podcast going when is David when is
David cross's dates Marshall are you
going to go through every date nope
we'll tell you when it starts and where
to go let's start with you then Portland
March 2nd who's going to listen to us
thank you uh St Louis will be in there
on this tour we'll be in St Louis uh and
this is worst daddy in the world tour uh
how many dates are you doing uh there's
gonna be three legs first leg which is
up there is 40 American cities couple
Canadian then the second leg will be and
now it's probably when this uh do you
say airs anymore
um and they'll have a they'll be three
legs eventually but uh and they'll be
England more of a I'll do Europe and uh
but more of Canada I'm only doing three
cities in Canada right now in this first
league but I'll do more I'll get to
Winnipeg and Regina and Edmonton and the
fun stuff and uh and then more American
dates etc etc great
officialdavidcross.com hardest I ever
laughed at a comedy special was yours uh
the last one no years and years ago the
mother Mary raped me oh my God that's
all that's the first one yeah I think
that's the first one it's the hardest I
ever lied to the comedy special
um but yeah so go see David Cross
everybody the website is official
davidcross.com
we have been on the road a little bit in
doing dates and stuff and I am actually
really enjoying I feel like there's a
sense of enjoyment from the audience
just to be out at shows right now so
you're looking for stuff to do please
come see our friends live experiences I
think that's what we missed a ton in the
last few years and yeah when was the
last time you all went on the road so
they've been kind of we've been going
back out but not we don't well I guess I
what was the break when covet hit what
was your I did end of 2021 and then
Omicron Delta [__] me for four months
and then I went back out I had it I was
about to go on tour which event which
resulted in the last special the I'm
from the future but I was going to go on
tour with that set and Delta omnicrom
just screwed it shut me down from
November to March and then I started and
even if Europe that was that was exactly
I added I was uh set to go out I think
in October and had to cancel the I've
never done it we were on the we were in
Madison Wisconsin when the world shut
down you were literally in Madison March
March 9th on a Thursday night and then
on Friday they were like I don't think
we can do these shows yeah we're like
all right let's hop on a plane and head
back we didn't do anything for another
year and a half yeah and then we've
recently started going like one we go
once a month you guys did that great
little run in Alaska and you know I
think what everybody's been waiting for
is what do you guys have coming up next
oh with us yeah at the end of uh at the
end of March we're gonna be at the uh
stand up live in Phoenix and we're gonna
all be together at the movie.com
Festival which we've done with you
before it's so much fun I remember a
wonderful time great comedy time
registering people to vote with you
that's right that was awesome that was
really fun that was great we did some
good work and we ended up uh
what was the Barbie uh uh lay barbecue
or was that where we went no it was it
we it was like a
outdoor slightly outside of the city a
little you know slightly uh and there's
like food trucks and it was like not
lemoy there's something in
it was so good it was amazing it was so
good good times I feel bad that I can't
remember the name of it okay somebody
will tell us there's probably a Pokemon
gym there and uh someone is shouting at
their thing yeah someone's getting into
a fight or at a thing uh no so we'll be
there in in April and then uh
Minneapolis then we're going back up to
Alaska we had such a good time that was
really fun just more dates like super
squads.com go it's we're sort of we're
spacing them out maybe like one or going
back to Ann Arbor in the fall of course
we'll put them all in there Daniel Van
Kirk danielvankirk.com come see my show
monthly in Houston or here in town or
moon tower great do it okay uh here we
go yes this was sent in by Carlene
McDermott at chibi Carlile here's a
headline friends man upgrades first ever
voice controlled [__] machine
activated by the words finish me
I mean this is a long time coming look
this is a long time because you don't it
doesn't get brought up but this does
sound like a pitch for a mystery show
sketch no no uh you have to go back and
say so a guy
uh read it again man upgrades first ever
voice controlled [__] machine
activated by the words finish me so is
the upgrade the words the voice
activation yeah yes
upgrade is I mean that's Loosely applied
here it's gonna do the thing what what
does it do once you go finish me what
does it changes it goes faster that's
not sometimes that's not that is
it looks you in the eyes is there a not
so quickly like you want to tell it I
mean it's a little distance to some
weird Mortal Kombat ending and yeah
finish me does is what could have been
said in the first story if you were I
don't you know it could be your wife I
don't know I've never been married but
long-term relationship or new and if you
said to a person during any sort of oral
pleasure finish me finish me that's
that's that feels very yeah pejorative
unless it's into your king not to shame
exactly also like who's saying like hey
Dave I really love your [__] machine
if it just had a voice command that
could have ended up it seems really hard
to go push that button uh are you up for
some unsolicited uh just yeah just a
couple notes
um loved it uh came a bunch uh that was
nice
um and I learned a bunch of things too
but uh by myself one one note
uh I kept saying finish me and that
didn't have any effect it was I wanted
it negligible if there wasn't and I at
all and I kept saying finish me and then
I could sense that I was getting
irritated and I didn't want to be out of
the moment the AI and I was like Fitness
what what are you and I'm thinking oh
wait you didn't program it it needs an
upgrade
issue with the chat GPT it's the same
thing it's never gonna get whatever
Never Gonna understand here we go the
inventor of the world's first voice
controlled [__] robot says he has
upgraded his Creation in protest at Big
tech companies Auto wait this is a move
of protest
Auto blow AI a crowdfunded male sex toy
why has now the people have spoken now
has a download notable [__] Library
honey what are you giving money to again
I'm an investor it's yell way too loud
I don't ask you what you said you spend
your money on why is that okay he now
has a downloadable [__] library that
gives users the ability to control their
oral robotic experiences this is what we
wanted at the beginning as well as
controlling the speed of the robot with
six voice commands including a finish me
mode sure users can now browse and
visualize
that thing when you started what if you
just whatever this thing is like a
flashlight or whatever yes I'm going to
show a mic stand that's hooked up to a
[__] uh generator generation like
okay here we go okay Finish me
Jesus Christ too much too fast
also I would want to say I don't know
his name I'll call him Kent also I would
be like Kent you know I love you
uh your version of finish me is not mine
everybody's version is different yeah
yeah I don't need a punch in the stomach
mine's a cup of tea yeah it's gonna be
told I'm good enough yes
um you want to take a gander at this guy
yes is he holding the thing he's holding
the auto blow and he's got one hand on
the upgraded version of the auto blower
yeah and the other one Mary
does he look exactly like you oh my God
that is that is an impressive [__] that
is so depressing also the like look it
won't if it's just a robot wait wait we
need to put so there is a describe it
please it's a woman's head oh God that's
a bummer
it's on what is this what can only be
described as in like a seventh grade AV
cart yeah but with an erector with good
uh materials there it's got like uh we
it's got four wheels it's a battle and
it's just like a mannequin head yes
very metallic uh robotic thing that is
uh two arms forward and well it's from
the forearm they're they're on kind of a
flexible looks like bendable kind of uh
metal and if you're watching on YouTube
we will put this image out that is most
of the art that's that's just going back
to one of the Erector Set beans and then
the uh more of an erection sound and
then the the forearm and two hands and
the head is on a pole yeah and then one
of the arms is holding uh uh it looks
like the
kind of headphones that people who bring
planes in and out yes or they put on
babies at concerts yeah or they put on
babies at concerts I mean it's that is
[__] depressing it is insane like if
you just saw that I was into it until
you showed me the picture so if you just
saw that you'd be like what did that you
have more notes you have more notes yeah
what did she do wrong that she's now
with the head on as well as uh
they can even activate the robot without
speaking at all so that's a long time by
pressing a button yeah exactly it's like
the old days just giving it a look
remote control there's a switch you'll
see two words one is own and the other
is and uh depending on which
you'd like to uh another another upgrade
is the user adjustable penis gripper
designed to cater to the size diverse
population everybody thought of
everything size diverse not everybody's
the right same size
yes for a [__] the robots for the
hand there's like there's another
gripper there's a grip there's a second
but it was designed for the size diverse
population I don't know what that means
it just means it can have different
levels of gripping what a size isn't
everybody's size it is what I'm getting
stuck on is the idea that it was that
the hand meaning the mechanical hand job
is developed for
different well
it's not a uniform it used to be uniform
and now now it has changed we've
upgraded that too the robot's Creator
Brian Sloan one letter away from alone
Brian Sloan said these are accessible
through a web app rather than an app
store in protest to Big text censorship
oh Stick it to protest he they won't let
him put this app on to uh Google Play
and the Apple uh App Store
a Sloan said if we self-censor sexual
language in order to reach people in
apple and Google's app stores we will
only re-stigmatize the normal sexual
behavior which millions of people have
worked for dozens or even hundreds of
years to know how many times has he
started that speech at a party and
everyone's like I'm just gonna go over
here and get it Brian we know Brian we
already invested yeah right we're the
choir Patrick the toilet is running we
want your jack off machine to work it's
not a jackoff machine job machine he
added speaking speaking is the main way
we express our sexual needs to our
partners is it is it
and I am working towards a feature where
where we will speak the same way to our
sexual devices so this guy's like a
month away from a Manifesto oh yeah this
guy is like so the last thing is where
he's working on something where we will
speak the same way to our sexual devices
to our partners in life he wants us to
be able to have that same finish me
okay check that one that's done slowly
graduated so tomorrow can you just pick
up the kids and take meds like you've
then revealed Sloan graduated from Law
School in 2005 but quickly decided he
had a brighter future in the field of
masturbation Tech sure he currently
holds seven patents in the field of sex
robots and his goal is to build an army
I'm joking a future
you've got everyone's goal who does that
a future work oral sex formed on a man
by a human is indistinguishable from an
experience generated by his Auto blow
machine just say you loved Judge Dredd
or Demolition Man
demolitionists
uh okay say you're not good at meeting
women people yeah that I gotta be bad at
that yeah this is weird change
I don't know what it is every time I
[__] go out on a date uh within an hour
of me mentioning that I'm making uh
robotic [__] machines they get wigged
out
just Jason I can't find somebody I can't
find my true love they start to clam
what's up with every other person in the
world except me everyone else is the
[__] just putting an entire oyster
into his mouth and he's like you like to
be finished
okay Finish me uh we'll get out of here
in this for fun
how much does the auto blow AI Plus cost
retail yes what is the retail price I
mean now that you show me the if I if I
hadn't seen that picture yeah
already getting into in a sense a little
bit
right yeah for a [__] you know what
the worst part is her face
the problem with this thing she doesn't
seem happy about this unamused yeah the
situation she's literally non-plus she
looks like the dude
without a goatee so but he he's breaking
down the problem with this cart is that
it if you really love it if it really
doesn't it will come okay oh you gotta
like take it with you like what luggage
does it fold down like once you love
your pillow it doesn't fold down no no
so you gotta roll that thing around the
halls of a hotel with you so it looks
like you would have to stand
you know you have to stand let's kind of
take something away from it maybe okay
how much do you think this cost anybody
want to go I'll go four thousand dollars
four thousand dollars
okay you can go last day I'm gonna say
seventy eight hundred dollars seven
thousand eight hundred dollars I'll go
812.72 cents the retail cost on the auto
blow AI Plus
you're never too early to shop for
Christmas is
299 dollars
yeah I felt like you were gonna be
around this is a this is a [__] you to
Big Tech he's trying to make this
affordable this point that we all can
guys everybody can get finished the
regular guy on the street the price of a
[__] has gone way up we need to
demonstrate to Stick it to the Man and
then finish me all right here's the last
story that we'll get to in a second
uh a woman who who fights the cops in a
very unconventional way okay good I love
it does she use a [__] machine maybe
does she say finish me we'll find out
right after this break uh David crosses
with us it's dumb people Town don't go
anywhere
[Music]
people town
hey everybody welcome back to DPT that's
done people Town
um maybe you're listening to this after
you've bought tickets to see David Cross
on his new tour maybe that's part of
this experience I hope it's an official
day you're probably using a device that
can get you those tickets right now yeah
pick them up go see him if you want to
see a great live stand up are you ready
for my final story for this game before
I have to pick up my son from basketball
practice let's do it woman accused of
unleashing bees on deputies serving an
eviction notice in Massachusetts so
she's I saw that headline I didn't read
the story but I saw it I'm like now
you're gonna get to wait so she has an
army she's amassing bees to be like if
anybody messes with me
um the queen it's like Rushmore yeah it
is like Rushmore uh this is sent by Nick
official parody at Nick Depp thanks Nick
here we go thanks buddy all right here
we go this was sent in a ton to us okay
uh a Massachusetts woman is facing
multiple assault and battery charges for
allegedly releasing a form of bees on a
group of sheriff's deputies some of them
is it wrong for me to have wanted all
the bees to be in the shape of an air
Arrow yeah going at them getting the
arrow and then look I so at some point
though
does she is she responsible for these
bees doing hey the cops wouldn't have
gotten stung if they would have just
complied okay
all right so but the once she shakes The
Hive the bees have a mind of their own
that's right yeah they're gonna come for
her too so she released them from a hive
well I think she has them maybe and I'm
gonna assume in like an old Tupperware
tin I don't think she's gotta just opens
him up this is a woman who keeps him
she's got it wait so she's gotta have a
soldier it's kind of a difference
whether whether she is running around in
a circle comically trying to avoid the
cops and then you know hit him
or let's get into it was she was it like
a apiere is that it Napier is uh that's
a bird
and then and then maybe she had an
apiary and and because she was a good
witch but the good kind of witch and
that she had her own honey yes her name
is Rory s Woods okay
pleaded not guilty at her arraignment on
October 12th in Springfield District
Court so in her brain this is how it all
goes down you're gonna mess with me I
release the yeah her lawyer did not
immediately respond to a voicemail left
by the associated president which means
he doesn't believe it he is not on her
side nope when you don't answer the
voicemail from that Associates do you
believe that your client is completely
uh you answer every voice man if you're
a lawyer I mean that's free publicity
but you're so off this woman that you're
like I don't even I don't want to answer
any voicemails the Hampton County
Sheriff's Department deputies went to a
home on Longmeadow in the morning of
October 12th were met by protest
protesters according to the official
Department report Woods who lives in
Hadley soon arrived in an SUV towing a
trailer carrying beehives okay so she's
got him with her she came to fight it
she brought it premeditated bought
malice right meditation to a fist fight
that's right report said she started
shaking the hives
broke the cover off one causing hundreds
of beefs to swarm out and initially
sting one Deputy how do they know how do
they know who's the bad what about the
proteins bees no cops that's right even
the beef and the bees even the bees the
uh Woods who put on a beekeeper suit to
protect herself she came prepared this
is premeditated that's why this guy's
not is your lawyers not answering
voicemails why would she plead not
guilty this was eventually handcuffed
but not before several more Sheriff's
Department employees were stung
including three who were allergic to the
bees the report said when Woods was told
that several officers were allergic to
the bees she said oh you're allergic
good
okay wow that's a pretty good quote I
mean what do you do though
she clearly did something wrong no no
they she showed up to a protest I think
where the Philippines does sound like a
skunk he knew the cops were going to
come to shut this protest down and
brought a bunch of bees
and again put all the protesters who
she's on their side in danger well
apparently they just stung the cops so
maybe they were trained maybe it's like
a Ben Willard's situation like we've we
yes
[Music]
that is really beautiful like an angel
Hampton County Sheriff Nick coochie
cochi said Woods could have faced more
serious charges if anything worse had
happened to those stung yeah I think
that's why she chose bees right we had
one staff member go to the hospital and
luckily he was all right said coachy we
will get out of here on this okay it's
Gucci excuse me how old is Rory s Woods
the woman who drove a truck of bees
premeditated put on a suit
put them in the shape of an arrow and
attack the cops I mean as she's putting
the bees think in the trailer together
she's definitely saying the phrase gonna
tell me gonna tell me what to tell me I
can't come tell me this gonna tell me
I'm gonna jump in and go 53 years old 53
Daniels that's kind of a Carol Baskin
type yes
yeah I'm gonna go 55. I think she's an
older girl too I think she's 64. 64. one
of you is exactly right wow so now we
get to play the game who do you think is
right you're gonna stay on 55. I'm
staying on 53. I'm standing on 64. okay
I'll switch over to 53. You're Gonna
switch okay uh get your answers in go
get tickets to see David he's really one
of the best for yourself in the world
he's someone we've loved forever and
we're friends with him and that means a
lot to us and so please go support him
any way you can thank you for being here
with us on this show uh and the answer
is Rory s Woods
I wish you would have stayed Dave 55
years
[Music]
come on
come on old enough to know better 55. uh
all right there you go that's a show
that's a show we love you guys thanks so
much and oh [__] we gotta get back to
work gang
[Music]